one of my absolute favorite parts of our
sundance interview
was how highly the two of you spoke
about each other
so now that we can get into specifics
what is one thing
the other did on set as a scene partner
that really made this collaboration
special
i have something um and it wasn't
necessarily
in this scene um right at the beginning
of production i think it was like a
couple of days of pre-production
we were shooting the journey that they
take
from the detention center to the house
and we're in a mini bus like
all day just driving around and there's
this shot of the the two characters
holding hands
women was so generous in sharing
something that was personal to her
about how she met her husband you know
and how and just sharing that story
well i mean i've loved with me for ages
so we would be wrong for me to say that
i fell in love with her then
but um her being that vulnerable with me
really helped me sort of
connect with her and then bold
connecting with real so it was just
about
me being open generous and sharing um
her
life and being open and free with me and
vulnerable with me that
i think set us off in an excellent
journey for the rest of the shoot
yeah i feel like the same i feel like
you i was gonna say like the the
openness
and the like generosity of spirit like
we
really bonded as like you know brother
and sister on that and on that
job and like can and has continued and i
feel like
um yeah that just that openness
that you know lying somewhat lying on
someone's lap
is not an easy thing to do when you
don't know a person it's just not
and um we were able to find that
physical vocabulary between us just
because we had opened up to each other
and been and shared i have to ask you
about working with remy too and
specifically i love hearing about what a
director's tell is behind the monitor
when they're really loving a take
and i'm really curious about him because
he seems so chill
and calm so what can you see him doing
behind the monitor when you know he's
really digging your performance
no i don't know i think i was beating
myself up so much trying to give him
exactly what he wanted
that i was like too in the scene to ever
see him out the corner of my eye
enjoying it but um do you have anything
you know it's really interesting because
he doesn't stop until he gets it
so you know you know you're not there
yet until
he goes i think we got it he just says i
think we got it and then we move on and
then
that's when you know we got it
all right some spoilers now i am always
so eager
to hear more about lore and legends so
did you two
do any extra research into the opeth or
just witchcraft in general among the
dinga you know
that scene i don't know if this ruins
the magic
but that scene was actually a reshoot so
we did that
a whole year later and um sorry
is that is that does that ruin them no
like if anything i think it's better to
kind of demystify
the negative connotation of a reshoot
like sometimes that's yeah right needs
to happen for the better
when i read that scene i just was just
i was just reading it because i didn't
really understand why we needed it
and then so that was more and then it
was actually in the playing of it that i
realized
oh i get it but so it was kind of a
it was more like an osmosis thing i
didn't really understand
it until we were in the scene i didn't
understand the true
need of that scene until we were there
they have the
apath speech and there's one point in
that conversation where bull
snaps at real and i was wondering
chope what what is what does he say to
her because i think that's one of the
very few moments in the movie where we
don't get an exact translation
sure yeah is what is the actual
word that he said and i think in dinka
it means enough
i drilled it so many times i'll never
forget
but he translates himself i think is
which is why it's not
um subtitled because it comes out in
dinka
and he's been trying to leave that out
uh
he's trying to remove that from himself
because he wants to be able to speak
english in a way that oh my goodness
reminds me of something that my parents
told me once but he wants to be able to
speak english in a way that will make
him
assimilate and acceptable to the white
people around him so he doesn't speak
his mother tongue anymore
and he's so frustrated in the moment
that he says it and then almost
quickly while still furious
translates himself back into english
because that's the angle he wants to
communicate in
um but yeah i think that's why it wasn't
subtitled
it's such a searing moment and i could
feel it in your reaction to that one me
that scene just crushes me every time
actually here's a scene with a little
more
i guess i would say a little more levity
well me i want to know about
your performance during the scene where
the caseworkers come in and bull almost
convinces them
to to leave you guys alone and then real
steps in and she says well
what about the witch what is the
motivating factor
behind her kind of blowing up his spot
in a sense is it purely revenge and can
you
feel that light tinge of comedy shining
through while you're on set
yeah i mean i think that's one of the
things i love about rial is that
she does have like comedy
little moments of like just lightness
and
even when he's having his nightmare at
the beginning she knows he's not
dreaming about
the wedding and you know like um
but um yeah i think for her her
motivation is
i want to go home i am going home i'm
gonna let these people know the truth
because i'm not gonna lie i'm not gonna
lie
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna give you
what you
like i'm not gonna perpetuate this
nonsense like let's go home
let's get our girl back let's go home
and
and they're going to look at us think
we're crazy and send us home
it's one of my favorite sequences in the
movie among many others but
chope for you i'll go with this specific
scene so the the moment where
bull decides to take nyanak because
there are some there are some shots in
that that let us just sit with you
without any dialogue actually
processing and making that decision so
in order to prepare for a scene like
that
what kind of conversations do you have
to have with remy to really solidify
where his mind is at when he makes that
choice
i don't know that we really had a
discussion about that moment
but the freneticism of what's going on
around
like i thought the supporting artists in
that scene did an incredible job of just
squeezing us against this bus
and reacting to the gunfire when it
happened
that it's it's calculated and it's not i
think that's one of the
themes of the of the film it's like what
do you do when you're trying to survive
when you're acting on instinct he knows
that maybe if he has this child
he'll gain access to the boss but i
don't think he obviously doesn't think
further down the line because carrying
this child across the sea into
into safety i was definitely never a
part of that plan in that moment so i
think um
super grateful to remy and yo for
capturing that because i don't think we
really spoke about it beforehand
it is uh it's mighty powerful as is the
whole film you guys know how i feel
about this one and i'm so glad people
are getting to see it now
huge congratulations thank you so much
see you guys yeah